Welcome back. We started the discussion of the distributive
systems with definitions and principles. We then saw how
object technology, with its innate concepts of inheritance and
reuse, helps in structuring distributive services at different levels.
In this next lesson module, we will discuss the design and implementation of
some select distributed system services. Technological innovation come when one
looks beyond the obvious and immediate horizon. Often this happens in academia,
because academicians are not bound by market pressures or compliance to existing
product lines. You'll see this out of the box thinking in the three subsystems
that we're going to discuss as part
of this lesson module. Another important point,
often the byproducts of a thought experiment
may have more lasting impact than the
original vision behind the thought experiment. History
is ripe with many examples. We will
not have the ubiquitous yellow sticky note,
but for space exploration. Now close to
home, for this course, Java would not
have happened but for the failed video-on-demand trials
of the 90s. In this sense the services we are going to discuss as part of this
lesson module, while interesting in their own right, may themselves be not as
important as the technololgical insights they offer on how to construct complex
distributed services. Such technological insights are
the reusable products of most thought
experiments. There's a common theme in
the three distributed subsystems we're going
to discuss. Memory is a critical,
precious resource. With advances in network technology
leveraging the idle memory of a peer in a Local Area Network may help overcome
shortage of memory, locally available in a particular
note. The question is how best to use
the cluster memory, that is the physical memory of peers, tend to be idle at any
particular point of time in a local area
network. Global memory system, GMS, asks the question,
how can we use the peer memory for
paging across the Local Area Network. And later
on we will see DSM, which stands for
distributed shared memory. Asks a question, if shared memory
makes the life of application programmers simple in
a multiprocessor, can we try to provide the same
abstraction in a cluster and make that cluster
appear like a shared memory machine. And a third
work that we will see is this distributed file system,
in which we ask the question, can we use the cluster
memory for cooperative caching of files. Anyhow, back to our first
part of this three-part lesson module, namely the Global Memory System.